GOOD AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO
THE COVERED NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHER
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THIS ORDER IS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT PUBLIC
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
ABUSING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND IT
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-692-8953 AGAIN.
877-692-8953 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN ZERO FIVE SIX
NINE SEVEN NINE AGAIN. SEVEN
ZERO FIVE SIX NINE OH NINE FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE.
COMMITTEE WEBSITE WHEN WE MOVE
THE PUBLIC CMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE ZERO FOUR SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO SIGN YOUR LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER THAT TIME
YOU'LL BE UN MUTED AND YOU'LL
NOW BE READY TO TRUST THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID CUSICK
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING THE
TESTIMONY YOUR TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO HEAR FROM YOU WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING IT IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHOSE
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE ARE
AFTER CONNECTIONS MUTED. FOR
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINED HEARING PROCESS
CONDUCTED HEARINGS IN THIS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNERS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS SO.
JUST TO THE NEW OF OUR- TOOLS
ARE TAKING. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL PATIENTS THAT ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
TODAY WILL BE HEARING ONE BILL
SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY FIVE CENTER
LIMON PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE
TWENTY NINE POINT ONE ZERO.
BEFORE HE THE PRESENTATION ON
THE BILLS WE SEE WE DON'T HAVE
A QUORUM YET- FOR BILL
TESTIMONY DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LIFE OF HEARING
SIGNALS CONSIDERATIONS IN
CLEANING PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE
CHAIR WILL INSTITUTE TIME
LIMITS ON BILL TESTIMONY. EACH
SIDE WILL BE PERMITTED AN EQUAL
AMOUNT OF TIME TO BE DETERMINED
BY THE CHAIR. FOR THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION FROM IT UP TO TWO
WITNESSES FOR TWO MINUTES PER
WITNESS OUR MAXIMO FOUR MINUTES
FOR EACH SIDE. ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN THIS
LIMITED COMMENTS YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. I HOPE TO HEAR FROM
EVERYONE WISHES TO TESTIFY.
BECAUSE WE HAVE A DEFINITE AND
TIME FOR THE HEARING OF THE
LIMIT THE TOTAL TIME FOR ALL
COMMENTS ON A BILL TO ENSURE
THAT COMMITTEES ABLE TO
COMPLETE OUR HEARING AGENDA
TODAY AND THAT THE SUBSEQUENT
COMMITTEES ABLE TO BEGIN ON
TIME. TIMELY MANNER. EVERYONE
ALSO HAS THE OPPORTUNITY SUBMIT
TESTIMONY ON ANY BILL BEING
HEARD TODAY ON THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE WEBSITE- GIVEN. YES
NUMBER SEVEN I BELIEVE A CENTRE
LIMóN I THINK WE ARE AT A
QUORUM I'M NOT MISTAKEN THREE
ELEVEN MEMBERS SERVE FIVE SIX
NO NO I THINK FOR ONE SHORT.
SIX MEMBERS. OF THIS NOW WE ARE.
OKAY YES OKAY WELL LET'S- AT
THIS POINT IN TIME BEFORE WE
BEGIN LET'S GO AHEAD AND
ESTABLISH A QUORUM CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. PAN CAN
HEAR MELENDEZ MULLIN IS HERE
EGGMAN GONZALEZ. GROVE YOUR
GROWTH HERE HER TADO LEYVA
LEYVA HERE LIMON LIMON HERE
ROTH ROTH HERE RUBIO. RUBIO
HERE WIENER. HERE K. WE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM- ACTUALLY
THOSE ARE VICE CHAIR OF A SEAT
ARE JUST ABOUT. OKAY ALL RIGHT
NEXT. OKAY WELL LET'S GO AHEAD
AND BEGIN- THE CEREMONY WELCOME
PLEASE BEGIN YOUR PRESENTATION
THANK YOU TURN COLLEAGUES I
WANTED TO FIRST START OFF BY
THANKING THE CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTING KIMBERLY
AT DH CS THE DEPARTMENT OF V.
GENE AND FOR THE PROVIDER
COMMUNITY FOR WORKING WITH ME
OVER THE LAST YEAR I TO
DESIGNED TO SUPPORT AND BUILD.
AS AMENDED IN THE ASSEMBLY SB
FORTY CREATES AN INNOVATIVE
PROGRAM TO GIVE MEDICAL
PROVIDERS TRAINING VALIDATED
ASSESSMENT TOOLS AND PAYMENTS
AND MS FOR CONDUCTING COGNITIVE
HEALTH ASSESSMENTS IN ORDER TO
ACHIEVE THE STATE WIDE GOAL OF
IMPROVED ALZHEIMER'S DETECTION
AND DIAGNOSES ACCORDING TO THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION LESS
THAN HALF OF THE INDIVIDUALS
LIVING WITH ALZHEIMER'S HAVE
BEEN DYING HAVE BEEN GIVEN A
DIAGNOSIS THE LACK OF A
DIAGNOSIS LEADS TO A NUMBER OF
CHALLENGES. RELATED TO PLANNING
CARE COST OF CARE AND
ENGAGEMENT IN CLINICAL TRIALS
OUR STATE HAS MODELED HOW MUCH
HOW SUCH A PROGRAM COULD BE
SUCCESSFUL TO THE ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES PROGRAM
ASUS THE PROGRAM PROVIDES
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES FOR
PHYSICIANS IS SERVING A MEDIC
CAL POPULATION TO CONDUCT A
SUBSCRIBING SB FORTY EIGHT
WOULD USE THIS MODEL FOR
ALZHEIMER'S AND DEMENTIA. THIS
BILL IS AN IMPORTANT STEP TO
ENSURE INDIVIDUALS RECEIVE A
TIMELY AND ACCURATE DIAGNOSES
WELL GIVEN PHYSICIANS THE TOOLS
TO EFFECTIVELY EFFECTIVELY
ASSESS A PATIENT'S CHANCES OF
HAVING ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE AND
DEMENTIA SB FORTY HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS RECEIVED
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER LIMóN-
WELL NOW MOVES TO WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT- I UNDERSTAND WE DO
HAVE ONE LEAD WITNESSES SUPPORT
CARE AND- GET RUSSO FROM THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION.
MODERATOR KEY PLEASE BRING-
THIS THIRD- ON THE LINE AND DO
YOU HAVE- TWO MINUTES. YEAH
THANK YOU- THANK YOU COMMITTEE
TEAR PAN AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JERRY JARRETT SO AND I'M THE
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR FOR THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION- I'LL BE BRIEF AND
MAKE A FEW KEY POINTS FIRST I
WANTED TO SHARE OUR AT THE
DECENT APPRECIATION- TO ALL
THOSE THAT WORK WITHOUT. AN
AUTHOR TO GET THE BILL TO THE
POINT OUR GOAL HAS ALWAYS BEEN
TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO TIMELY
DIAGNOSIS ALL CALIFORNIANS WHO
ONGOING ENGAGEMENT AND GUIDANCE
FROM THE CHAIR THE COMMITTEE
THE PHYSICIAN COMMUNITY THE
ADMINISTRATION DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND
DEPARTMENT OF AGING WE BELIEVE
THAT WE HAVE A BILL THAT GETS
SHORT BALL BETTER ACCESS TO
TIMELY DIAGNOSIS. I CAN'T
ABSOLUTELY MON MENTIONED THIS
CONCEPT IS MODELED AFTER THE
ACT NOT WORK OUR STATE HAS DONE
RELATED TO ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCE. IS OR EVEN BY
INCENTIVIZE THE COGNITIVE
HEALTH ASSESSMENT FOR NON GO
ELIGIBLE MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES
SIXTY FIVE AND OVER PHYSICIAN
CHOOSING TO RECEIVE THESE
INCENTIVES WILL NEED TO
COMPLETE THE MEASURE PACIFIC
TRAINING AS WELL. FINALLY THE
PROPOSAL FILLED AN IMPORTANT
GAP IN OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
FOR INDIVIDUAL BY MEDICAL ABOUT
ACT THAT THE MEDICARE WHILE
MEDICARE OFFERED SIMILAR
BENEFIT WITHIN THE ANNUAL
BONUSES THAT OVER A HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
OVER FIFTY FIVE YOU DON'T
CURRENTLY HAVE ACCESS TO THE
BENEFITS WITH THE PROGRAM
OUTLINED IN AT THE FORTY EIGHT
WE CAN FINALLY FILL THE GAP.
WHILE THIS BILL FOCUSES
SPECIFICALLY ON THAT HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THOUSAND- IN
INDIVIDUALS ON THOSE ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUAL WE BELIEVE THAT THE
PROPOSAL IS AN INNOVATIVE STEPS
TO ADDRESS THE MASSIVE GAP IN
DIAGNOSIS FOR THOSE LIVING WITH
DEMENTIA AND SHOULD HAVE
BROADER BENEFITS WHEN
IMPLEMENTED WELL I PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED COGNEX GREENING-
BENEFITS WITHIN MEDICARE PLUS
IN A QUARTER BENEFICIARIES
RECEIVE THAT. BENEFIT
CALIFORNIA NOW HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TRULY LEAD THE
WAY IN A WAY OUTLINED BY THE
ALZHEIMER'S PASSPORT IN THE
MASTER PLAN FOR EACH AND HOW WE
CAN FINALLY ADDRESSED THE
FOUNDATIONAL CHALLENGE TIMELY
DIAGNOSIS AS AN OPPORTUNITY A
PLAN TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
LIFE. TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
TARGETED PROGRAMS AND TO
PARTICIPATE IN CLINICAL TRIALS.
THAT WILL ULTIMATELY LEAD TO A
TREATMENT AND IT'S SURE. WE FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AT THE EIGHT TODAY
THANK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO DIGITAL
WITH AND WITH WITH- ROOM UNDER
DISH WITNESSES- AND ROOM ARE
WILL MOVE THROUGH TWENTY FOUR-
SEEN ONE ROOM TWENTY. MODERATOR
FREEZE PLEASE ON THE LINE
WITNESSES WHO WISHES TO AND- OF
SB EIGHT NAY OR IS AND ONLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
SB FORTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB FORTY EIGHT. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
POINT TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PRICE
DOUGHERTY ON BEHALFOF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS IN STRONG SUPPORT
AND WE JUST LIKE TO APPLAUD
GENERAL AMOUNT FOR WORKING WITH
US TO ENSURE. THAT PATIENTS
SUFFERING FROM COGNITIVE
DISEASES SUCH AS ALZHEIMER'S
AND DEMENTIA. RECEIVE AN
APPROPRIATE DIAGNOSIS AND
TIMELY CARE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AGAIN NAME OPPOSITION
POSITION ONLY ADDITIONAL IN
THIS IS A SUPPORT. AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB FORTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND
THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AND GIVING THANK YOU-
WILL NOW MOVE TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO FORMALLY
LISTED WITH THIS IN OPPOSITION
FOR TESTIMONY SO WILL THEN MOVE
TO ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AND- YOU KNOW WHAT
THIS ROOM. FORTY TWO OR THREE
SEEN ON FORTY TWO THREE LET'S
MOVE TO RUN TWENTY FORTY. THREE
KNOWN IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO THE A
TELEPHONIC LINE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE TO
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB. FORTY
EIGHT AGAIN NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU MR.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
OF SB FORTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FORTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO. WE HAVE NO COMMENT TO
QUEUE AT THIS TIME I THANK YOU
KNOW THAT BRING YOU BACK
COMMITTEE- QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY TO MOVE BY CENTER LEYVA.
PASSING NO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS- CEREMONY FIRST OF
ALL I JUST WANT THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH FOR WORKING WITH ME-
AND- YOUR ADVOCACY FOR. THE
ALZHEIMER'S COMMUNITY I KNOW
THAT WHEN THE BILL FIRST
STARTED ACTUALLY WHEN TO BEANS
HE AROUND SENIOR REQUIREMENTS-
BUT- I URGE YOU AND APPRECIATE
YOU LISTENING THAT WE ACTUALLY
SHOULD ACTUALLY MOVE THE NEEDLE
AND ACTUALLY. NOT STOCK UP
TELLING TO TELLING PEOPLE THEY
SHOULD BE DOING THIS LET'S
ACTUALLY. INCENTIVIZE AND
CREATE THE SUPPORTS THAT THE-
POSITIONS AND OTHER HEALTH
PROVIDERS NEED TO BE SURE THAT-
WE ACTUALLY DO THIS KIND OF
SCREENING THAT YOU'RE SEEKING.
SO AGAIN I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE ON
THIS AND SOMETHING VERY FULL
SUPPORT AND- APPRECIATE TO YOU
PARTNERING WITH ME AND- MY-
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO HELP
SUPPORT YOU IN YOUR- VEHICLE SO
WITH THAT- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. IT YOU KNOW AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU AT THIS BILL WAS
IN A DIFFERENT WAY FOR US STILL
WITH SUPPORT BUT IT WAS
DIFFERENT WAY AND I DON'T KNOW
IF PEOPLE. REALLY UNDERSTAND
HOW. IMPACTFUL THIS IS GOING TO
BE IN A POSITIVE WAY AND I HAVE
TO THANK YOU YOUR COMMITTEE
EVERYBODY. FOR HELPING US GET
TO THIS PLACE BECAUSE T HAS
TURNED ON AND I THINK IT'S
GOING TO IT'S REALLY EXCITING
WHAT WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO DO
FOR CALIFORNIANS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR HAVE.
THANK YOU CENTRAL AMOUNTS SO
THE MOTION IS THAT THIS ONLY
MINUTES BE CONCURRED. AND IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY CENTER LEYVA.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HI. AM I AM A- MELINDA'S NO.
CONSOL GONZALEZ I GREW. OKAY
HER TADO I THE TOTAL I LEYVA
LEYVA AYE LEE MON I AGREE
MONNING AYE ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO
RUBIO AYE WIENER WIENER HI.
PLEASE HELLO I AM A I WANT TO
SET THE WHOLE ROLE YEAH OKAY SO
THE ROLE OF THE IS EIGHT TO
ONE. THE BILL DID MENACE
MINUTES OR CONCURRED AND- WITH
THAT WE CONCLUDED THIS AGENDA
OF THIS HEARING OF THE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH AND I THINK
ALL THE INDIVIDUAL SUPPOSED TO
DISAPPEAR PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY IF YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS
AND WRITING TO THE SENATE
HEALTH COMMITTEE OR BETTER
VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY
INDIVIDUAL HEARING RECORDS
THANK YOU APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION NOW THANK
EVERYONE FOR. DEPT IS PAYING
THIS HEARING WILL CONCLUDE THIS
AGENDA THE SENATE. COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH IS NOW ADJOURNED. THANK
YOU.